[Music]
I'm a McDonald and Mrs Nam and today
we're going to be talking about how we
construct and query a data model for
online harm this right now means nothing
to you and that's okay we'll bring you
there
so like I said uh I'm atar I am in
charge of all things uh data pointed and
active sense and I'm Noah I'm a big data
engineer with octopins
and so what do we do at act defense uh
we uh are focused on making the internet
a safer place what does that mean uh
protecting the Integrity of every online
interaction uh with the goal of leading
to a safer World both online and then
that translates to offline eventually uh
we our clients are any platform that has
user generated content so anywhere where
a user can upload chats videos audio
what have it that's a place a potential
place for harm
and so what we've seen from our work is
that harmful content really is
multi-dimensional what does this mean so
on the left hand side here
um this is a live streaming of the
Christ Church shooting so
um the mass murder went in and
videotaped himself killing people at
prayer
and on the right hand side it's kind of
maybe more difficult to see is a video
game reenacting that basically enabling
the player to be the Christchurch
shooter okay this sort of this video
game kind of blurs the line right
between online and offline harm we can
take an off an offline terrible event
and then gamify it and so this is an
example of sort of white supremacy
embedded in a game
foreign
we can also see here uh harmful content
sort of on our favorite
um podcast or audio streaming platforms
uh sometimes it's really easy to spot
and sometimes it's a little trickier
so I don't know how many of you guys are
familiar with this symbol this is the
Celtic cross it's a symbol that's been
appropriated by white supremacist groups
Neo-Nazi groups
rehoa that sounds for racial holy war
okay
and 1488 where 88 is HH Heil Hitler 14
stands for us it's the number of words
in a sentence we must secure the future
for white children and our descendants
and so this is sort of the kinds of
things that you can see even on just
regular platforms right and so sometimes
it's sort of things that you have to
know and you have to understand but it's
there
another example NSM radio so NSM
National Socialist movement Nazi radio
and finally for those of you that are
less familiar this is
logo uh so she had songs or prayers and
so forth and so again this is not in the
darkest deepest corners of the deep dark
web right this is just out there
another example uh for anyone who's not
familiar this is the Isis logo so if
anyone wants instead of a conference
shirt you can go and find one of these
again this you know is embedded in
images and so forth merchandise
so hopefully until now what I've
convinced you is that harmful content
detection is also a multi-dimensional
problem right we can see it across
different languages uh different types
of violations so I showed you hate
speech white supremacy Terror but we
also have child safety misinformation
mass shootings and so forth
um and also any different format right
anytime that a user can upload content
whether it's chats or images or videos
or audio that's those places are all
places where harmful content can make it
in
okay
so what can we do
so one thing we can do is we can have
object and can anyone else hear that
awful buzzing I'll I'll just stand
um so one thing we can do is uh we can
look for objects and faces right so this
is an example of one algorithm that we
have so a logo detection algorithm
that's trained to find malicious logos
in this case Isis and what's nice is
that it can find them when they're sort
of hidden occluded 3D on flags and so
forth and so great we can find Isis
logos excellent we see this picture
now you all know what the Isis logo
looks like
is this malicious
maybe right Maybe not maybe if we zoom
out and we look a little bit wider then
we can see oh actually you know yeah
this is the Isis logo but it's on CNN so
now we have an interplay between
different logos that we need to find and
the presence of the other logo suddenly
makes this not malicious and so we
always have to look sort of at the
broader context
here's another example
what about this
silence everyone knows it's a trick
question so
it depends right so the text is fine
right it's benign I love him that's
completely fine
what about now
maybe a little less suddenly it's more
interesting right still who knows right
there's a broader context here but at
least that's something worth looking at
right suddenly the user is more
interesting there's something more more
interesting at play here than just a
text by itself
so what I'm trying to hone in here is
that risk analysis is also multimodal
here's another example
and then is usually glued in there and
then there's a handle material that's
shaped on top of that here's an example
of a hidden Tang knife with no handle on
it so it gives you a good sense of
what's
he goes on and on and on uh and so any
image recognition algorithm object
detection algorithm would scream knife
knife knife knife means what weapon
weapon weapon yeah it's true the knife
it's a weapon okay
but if we zoom out and we analyze the
soundtrack what's being said we look
where it's posted what is being said
then this is a knife maker explaining
the difference between Chef's knives
okay and if you look just at the picture
his hands are all cut up he's using a
knife he's slicing something maybe
that's a body part it's a tomato but you
know maybe not
um and so you always need to sort of
zoom out look a little bit further right
it's not enough to just analyze the
video not left to just not enough to
just look at the soundtrack not enough
to just think about oh you know what uh
what are the keywords or what's being
said there's a bigger picture here and
together it's the interplay right here
we have
um we before we had you know a benign
text with a potentially malicious
malicious image here we have an image
that maybe is malicious with things that
were detected and so there's always sort
of a broader picture that we need to
look at and one thing that we always
need to keep in mind when we're trying
to find and detect harmful content is
that we are in an adversarial space so
every time we get better
our adversary gets better too
so here's an example
I have this you know this came in and I
have you know my my uh my object
detection algorithm and so I said okay
it's a sweatshirt and I'm analyzing the
text and it's a domestic hoodie and I'm
checking all the boxes and everything's
okay
what about this
domestic terrorist and one thing that
that we really leverage within act
defense is also intelligence analysts so
they're basically able to tell us what's
going on right so this is actually
something that's associated with the
alt-right and with some groups that are
banned um so for being like far right
and uh white supremacist and so forth
and so here we'd say okay well now so
it's not enough to have object detection
it's not enough to have NLP we also need
OCR now right so we're always looking
for new ways and new techniques that we
can extract more information from the
data that's come in more algorithm we
add more algorithms more indicators we
call them for how we can find
information from embedded within the
data that's coming in right and a lot of
these we're live really heavily on the
fact that we also have intelligence
analysts and research within the
organization and they can basically tell
us you know keep the finger of the pulse
of what's coming you know what new logos
what new phrases and so forth
and even yet
it's even more difficult right because
here so I can do OCR okay I can do NLP I
can do object I can do everything and
yet this is really easy to miss so I
don't know who here is familiar with Q
Anon okay it's uh misinformation sort of
bans on some platforms and so if you
read what they wrote here they said we
were told to camouflage our channels so
we did with q c u e okay no one's going
to catch that right you have to know to
look for that it's not the letter it's
not this it's just taking a word out of
changing the way that it's used
and so this has started to get you
thinking about okay so even now we would
need like another way to extract this
thing from here we need to look even
further the context to really understand
how this is being used uh and and
basically so we can detect it and catch
it
so hopefully until now I've managed to
convince you that the world is complex
context is everywhere and it's and
anything can be context right and so the
big question that drives us is how can
we capture the complexities of the
online world at scale okay across all
different platforms and all different
violations
and can we make it simple no I'm
well I really hope we can can you hear
me yeah so essentially what we want to
do is to construct a data model that
will help us capture those different
complexities between different entities
right we want the video of the knives in
the streaming platform with its
description and the the photo of the
shirt and the e-commerce platform with
the title of it and so on and as Mata
said we want to do that across different
platforms and across uh violation so
first we'll construct a data model that
will help us capture all of that and
then see how we can leverage it uh to to
make smart decision about content online
now uh before before we start
constructing our data model the first
thing we we need to do and this is a
general note about the data modeling is
to understand the the problem domain we
want our data model to be aligned as
much as we can with uh with our
potential clients uh data model and how
they see the world because this way
we'll be able to to preserve most of
their semantics so let's start by
understanding a bit more how uh how how
potential clients platforms look like uh
in active for instance case it's it's a
user generated content platforms so uh
one example will be a social media
platform I hope most of you are familiar
with LinkedIn so in LinkedIn we have a
user which is a real person identity
hopefully a real person identity in the
platform
we have a group which is a group of
users under the same domain it could be
data scientists in Israel or data
engineers in San Francisco or Scala
haters and we also have a post which is
essentially a piece of content a user
creates it it could have a text an image
a video maybe all of those
so those are the base entities and on
top of that we have a comment now a
comment if you think about it is pretty
similar to to a post it's a piece of
content a user creates but it has a
context it's a comment to a post it's a
comment to another comment Maybe
and we have a page or a company page now
a company a company page can be thought
of as a private case of a group it's
it's a group a group of users under the
same domain the company's domain
so this is an example of a social media
platform let's take a look at another
example of a chat platform
I hope you're familiar with WhatsApp
um so in WhatsApp again we have a user
which is a real person identity in the
platform we have a group which is a chat
of one or more users and we have a
message which is a piece of content a
user creates it might also have uh an
audio attached to it
and uh so and if you think about other
chat platforms you're familiar with or
for example let's take a telegram so it
consists more or less of the same
entities maybe it's not a group it's a
channel
but uh but it's the same idea
and I think we are comfortable enough to
start constructing our own data model
and as always when it comes to data
modeling there is a trade-off between
the the abstraction and the semantics so
if we add more layers of abstraction to
our data model we will lose some of the
semantics and we will uh choose to
preserve most of the semantics we will
lose the abstraction across different
platforms
but just a note to keep in mind
So based on what we saw example so we
saw we can come up with this uh with
this data model so we have a user a
collection that has a collection type it
might be a page it might be a group
and we have a Content which uh has a
content type might be a post maybe a
message or a comment
and apart from that all of those has the
the different uh relationships in line
okay
now this approach doesn't work and it
doesn't work from two main reasons one
is that it's not very scalable so
um let's say we would like to support
new platform that has different
relationships between its different
entities will have to extend our schema
to support uh this new relationship so
for example some platforms has
collections of Collections and for that
we'll have to extend our collection
schema to support this type of
relationship and we'll end up extending
our schema again and again for for each
platform we would like to support its
new relationships and some attributes
will make sense for for some use cases
but won't make any sense for other use
cases
so it's it's not very scalable this is
one problem can anyone see the other
so we are trying to to maintain
many-to-many relationships here and we
have it in several places but for
example on the content schema we have a
comments which is uh another uh piece of
content right so let's understand why
why it's problematic so this is a this
is a comments for for a post in social
media platforms so a post has a list of
its comments which again are a type
again comments a contents sorry and each
of those comments has a list of its own
comments and so on and so on so let's
say you would like to delete one of
those comments we'll have to find that
post and Traverse this contents three to
find the comment and delete it so it's
hard to maintain this way
another example is that a group has a
list of its users subscribe to it and
each user has a list of of the groups he
or she is subscribed to so again we're
facing the same problem and and if we
pinpoint the problem here is that we're
trying to uh to to to capture uh or to
model uh graph data relationships
intensive in a tabular way
so what we decided to do with attack
defense is to add two more entities to
the to the schema so one is a media
which is essentially a thin element that
just captures singular media item that
the text the audio the video the image
and the relation entity and the relation
captures the relationship between
different entities and this can be also
thought of as relations from graph
Theory so the relation type will be uh
the predicate for example is comment off
is a description of different type of
relations uh in that field in the
subject and the object captures the
order or who relates to whom
and let's see an example to understand
it better so in this example we have a
relation type of is created by so the
content of type post is created by the
user hence the content is the subject of
the sentence and the user is the object
of the sentence and therefore the
content is the subject of the relation
and the user is the object of the
relation another example here is the
easy comment off relation type to
capture relationship between a comment
and a post so the content of type
comment is the subject of the relation
and the content of typos is the object
of the relation because the comment is a
comment of of a post
and we can we can see here now that the
if we take a look at the content for
example the the the schema is much
thinner
so uh in particular the media is not
captured in line it will be captured
using the media entity and other
relation type to describe this type of
relationship and let's see how how IT
addresses the the two problems we we saw
earlier so first uh let's say you would
like to support new platform with new
relationships between its different
entities all we have to do is to add
another relation type to capture the
relationship between those entities
um and and for the many-to-many
relationship here let's let's say we
would like to delete the comment so the
comment now is an entity with its own
rights all we have to do is to find this
entity and we can delete it and all the
relations attached to it
and uh much easier
and this is a this is a real world
example so we have a user in a social
media platform uh Donald Trump one of
his posts so again the post is created
by the user by you Donald Trump and one
of the comments to that post is comment
of Donald Trump post
uh but as I said earlier the the media
will not be uh captured in line and will
be captured using a media item and
another relation type
and this is how it's persisted if if we
would persist it in in Json lines for
this example so we just have the entity
type and the ID
and uh this is a Content so we capture
the content type within it and this is
an example of how we persist the the
user
um and the relation entity which also
can be thought of as the edges in the
graph and the content the user are the
the nodes in the graph so uh again the
relation type is is created by and the
subject ID and the object ID points to
to the ID of the uh content and the user
respectively
and this is for for the media so the
media item holds the text in line and
another relation type captures the
relationship between the media and and
the post
so what we've seen so far we started by
understanding the the problem domain and
after we did that we we started
constructing our data model using the
relation entities that that made it uh
cross-platform and scalable
now uh constructing a data model that is
abstract enough is one task and
constructing another model that is
abstract enough and easy to work with
and maintain is a completely different
task and we did have uh some challenges
with it
so uh by the way we are working with
Spock and we are at in a python
conference so we're looking at Pi spark
code and let's say we want to query that
data and again let me remind you it's
persisted there for the example in Json
line so we essentially reading all the
data and filtering for data frame of
contents of type of type post another
data frame of relations uh with the
relation type is is created by okay if
we want to collect this post uh user
data
and another data frame of the users now
we have to do uh two joints here
essentially
um we need to to join the the contents
that are referring the post data frame
with the uh with the relations data
frame or the edges of the graph and join
the result with the uh with the user
data frame and the the post ID should
match the the subject ID and the of and
the user's ID should match the object ID
because uh the the user is the object of
the relation and the content is the
subject of the relation
and the the main challenge here is that
one that want to create that data has to
know for each relation type who's the
subject and who's the object and it
turns out it's not an easy task because
if you think about it it depends on how
you phrase it so in this example it is
created by so the post is created by the
user so the the contents the content of
type post is the subject and the user is
the object but it could as well have
been is Creator off and in this example
the user is creator of the post and
therefore the user is the subject now
and the content is the object so one
that want to create a data has to know
for each relation type who's the subject
and who's the object to make a proper
join and uh and at its very over prone
so this is how we uh we addressed it
um the this code does exactly the same
as the code we saw before so we we
developed a lib that that actually
abstract those two complexities so so
let's go over it quickly
so what we're doing is initiating the
library with the the path with the path
for the for the data and creating a data
frame of contents of type post and
declaring the the context we want to
collect about our data or the relation
types we want to join our data frame
with
and passing those to to the library the
now the library under the hose in under
the hood in first for each relation
types we Supply who's the subject and
who's the object of it uh reads the
other data frames and uh and make those
joins and this is not an open source so
why am i showing you that at all and the
answer is that uh even though your data
model might get complex because the
problem domain is complex you can still
uh develop tools that will help your
engineers and your researchers across
the the are in the organization to work
easier and faster with that data model
okay
so let's uh wrap it up now by by
catching Bin Laden in a social media
platform so we have the the example from
from the previous slide
I've been loading the social media
platform we are we now all know that uh
it's a content right
and this content has two Medias attached
to it uh the first one is the uh text so
what we can see here it's how it modeled
the text is in line and again the
relation entity to capture the
relationship between the text and the
post
and we have another media here the image
so it's captured here using the is body
media of relation type in the relation
entity
and this is how we query it using the
library so again we are creating another
frame of the post and declaring the
context we want to collect about our
data or the relation types we want to
join with pass those two to the library
and and getting the the result the user
the the data sorry about uh about this
post its Medias in this example
and we we can extend it much more of
course this was just a simple example so
we can collect data about the user who
posted that post using the relevant
relation type is created by collect all
the text Medias all the image Medias and
data about those who commented those who
shared those who liked
and take all these users uh data and the
scores we gave to their previous posts
and send all those texts to the text
analysis and all the images to the image
analysis and so on and so on now once we
gathered all that information what can
we do with it
so if you remember from before we
discussed that what we have is we have
these indicators right so that's that's
here right this is all what we're
extracting and the data model basically
enables us to map the indicators to the
data okay and so after we have all those
what we can do is we can send them we
can extract features send them off to a
model and generate a risk score they
basically will give us the probability
that this item is violated based on what
we extracted and where it was embedded
uh in the content itself and in the post
and so uh hopefully today we managed to
convince you that uh harmful content
detection is an interesting problem
harmful content is everywhere not to
scare you uh that it's that we're able
to find it we're able to detect it and
however in order to do that at scale we
need to have a data model that basically
is what enables us to do it uh with the
right level of complexity uh and scale
across different types and platforms and
violations and formats uh and so just to
wrap it up
and act defense uh we do great things
for the World online uh and so thanks
and come join us we're hiring
questions
yeah
so just to rephrase so that we've never
learned just to make sure that I said
are you asking if in in the risk model
and the end risk model we also take into
account where uh like where things were
embedded in the content itself if it was
if the text was in the title or if it
was in the description or if it was in a
comment
or for user yeah so that's so okay and
also asking relations between users and
so forth so for that what we discussed
is um we were discussing different
levels of context right and so we have
uh even within like a language model you
have the local context of like how aware
disease versus just using keywords and
you know you can keep abstracting out
and so another level of context is the
user right so what other content did the
user share uh and you know and what who
liked it and what groups were they in
and so forth and so any any information
that we that we can get our hands on yes
it's something that that we can leverage
absolutely
yes
so the question was what what we do with
with like flat tables
you like another so so
um yeah so I I can start the answer and
then if you want to if you want to like
add something
um the idea is that our data model this
is something that Noms in the beginning
our data model is meant for the kind of
world that uh we operate in which is uh
platforms with user generated content so
you know you saw the LinkedIn example
and lots of exam so that's that's what
we can that's what we model now we can
leverage other sources of data whether
like you know flat data whether it's on
the level of our indicators right so you
know um if we have like for example
um a text model that can that identifies
um uh hate speech right then then that
you know within that within that realm
um then it can leverage uh tabular data
right so it depends on like the the
tabular data would feed in in some point
uh at the level of the indicators and
not necessarily at the end level of sort
of the big Ensemble
um because again the The Ensemble is
based on data that we can extract from
the kinds of platforms that that we deal
with did that maybe that
so so more both I guess if I understood
your question he asked if we walk in
real time
so yes both
I'm not sure you have time
you're saying yeah okay yeah go ahead
uh so the question was how do we scale
uh and so again
um the what what enables us to scale is
the fact that our language model or our
data model
um is like like economics like economics
it's extendable right so you can add a
more relation you can model things
differently and then what we have is we
have different models that run and can
extract information from the content
that's coming in so for example you
mentioned the language model
um so it's not simple uh and and uh the
people the people that that wrote it are
right there uh
and uh and so and so the language model
is one is one component that basically
given that given that you know that we
could map that you know this is a
description or a title or whatever then
we know that it's you know text not an
image then it can run on that and then
um we're able to serve that
um in real time or near real time
um with the people that are sitting
there uh and uh and then and then put it
all together it's a generative score
so yes so serving large language and
repeating for the benefit of all uh
serving and serving large large language
models uh is technologically challenging
and so that's true and so we're always
playing this game between like you know
what is the size of the model what what
have our
um what what is the limitations that we
have and then also pushing the envelope
in terms of uh technology and um and
things that we do in order to be able uh
to give in so you know we can we work
together right within the teams we have
Engineers we have data scientists and
then so working together to say okay
given that we have a language model uh
and it's the you know this is what we
need to get to this level of precision
that we want how can we how can we serve
it like what is the right architecture
you know can we you know do we batch it
like what do we do to get it there and
so yeah we're that's that's exactly
where we feel the same pain points too
and that's where uh we're working on
absolutely
mm-hmm
great thank you
[Applause]
[Music]